what has come to be called the Hindu
tradition is a rich fabric of
civilization interweaving numerous
threads and hues of religious life
the intricate blend of Aryan Dravidian
and various tribal cultures has resulted
in a rich variety of religious practices
a diverse region of many peoples and
languages and various forms of worship
through the many manifestations and
images of the divine this dynamic
network of religious currents is
therefore better represented in the
plural as Hindu traditions formulations
and reformulations of these currents
have continued through the centuries and
they continue today as Hindus in
communities throughout the world reshape
traditions in the context of their
contemporary societies while Hindu
currents of thought and practices have
flourished on the Indian subcontinent
for at least three millennia the concept
of Hinduism as a world religion as a
unitary package of beliefs and rituals
akin to Christianity or Islam or
Buddhism emerged only in the nineteenth
century colonial context via processes
much debated in scholarship over the
past three decades while there are many
divine figures each with many names and
forms a large number of hindu worshipers
would insist that this many nests must
be understood in relation to a radical
oneness expressed through the concept of
brahmana understood as the reality that
transcends all personal names this one
reality call it brahman the divine or
the real can be perceived in and through
an infinite number of names and forms
the earliest literary sources of the
Hindu tradition are the Vedas literally
knowledge a body of ancient hymns and
chants composed in the second millennium
BCE sometimes referred to as Shruti
meaning literally what is heard the
Vedas were not read on the page but
recited orally in metered verse the
apana shads
considered the end of Vedas and dating
largely from the eighth to the sixth
centuries BCE are their wisdom
literature and take the form of
dialogues between teachers and students
reflecting about the origin basis and
support of the universe
what is the cause what is Brahman whence
are we born whereby do we live on what
are we established so asks the seeker in
this fittest Vitara Upanishad the
teachers of the upon Assad's point the
way to a profound realization that Atman
the innermost self or breath of life is
identical with Brahman the ultimate
reality that pervades the entire
universe along with these texts of
philosophical reflections another set of
texts called the Dhamma Shastras were
composed in the centuries before the
Common Era these focused on moral and
social duties of individuals based on
their place in the society and their
station in life the philosophical
reflections of the Upanishads and the
moral injunctions laid out in the Dharma
Shastras were woven into two epics the
Ramayana and the Mahabharata the
mythological Campania called the Puranas
which have been the core texts of
Hinduism since the early centuries of
the Common Era contain hundreds of
narratives about divine manifestations
and form the basis of varied religious
expressions through ritual pilgrimage
music and dance
numerous retellings and spin-offs of the
narratives contained in the epics and
the Puranas are also found in popular
vernacular texts that serve as
scriptures for different groups
especially those outside of elite
communities daily worship often offered
two images in a household shrine might
be directed to a particular God a
goddess or related figure with whom an
individual or family has a special
affinity Hinduism is closely identified
with India where more than 95 percent of
the world's Hindus live in the millennia
prior to widespread euro-american
contact and colonial rule religious
identities throughout South Asia tended
to be particular context-sensitive and
somewhat fluid Hindu as an identity
marker grew more significant as its
scope
both expanded and contracted during the
struggle for independence from Britain
the British partition of Bengal in 1905
and later of India in 1947
into hindu-majority & muslim-majority
areas generated a linking of religious
and national identities however there
are Hindu communities in virtually every
part of the world today
you